here we go Trey flipping the building
keep going T yo insane on the mic listen
I finna go beast mode with the end they
came on like [ __ ] hitting the chico
feasting on wack rap bus laughing jack
they're too short
keeps you 100 like a long pack of
Newports hella fellows bladder stabbing
my back I wrote a new to me usually rude
to be jealous because the girls choosing
me
never trust [ __ ] that can't walk in
their own neighborhoods they never wife
a [ __ ] that won't you only cuz your
papers good I've been to jail twice
mister I ain't a [ __ ] a liar you can
call me Richard I got a couple of priors
I was stuck in jail cuz I wasn't PD and
I pay my [ __ ] bail with her financial
aid check rappers burn fake beef hella
irrelevant mission never accomplished
opposite of intelligent been on some
Obama demolish hip-hop Tara's mopping
the block two dreadlocks that's why they
scared of us hilarious
I'm a me I'm a bo dude eight out of the
girl from South Korea [ __ ] soul food I
had to slurp on a cookie teardrop
tattoos on my dick cuz I murdered a
[ __ ] if you actually asking me if I had
to be picking up on some natural
National Geographic Oh titties [ __ ]
double D's my [ __ ] 30 a quadruple Z's
than titties so big they've been to fall
asleep now my mom washer emergency I
tried to better trade flip that [ __ ]
murdered me deliver for metaphors I
started to feel with his devil horns
they took me out with a medic order
urgently need some surgery huh keep it
going bro
yo how come every rapper is claiming to
be anti label happy to be the same
[ __ ] with zero offers on the table
don't got a deal don't need a deal um
independent bravery I own all my
Master's [ __ ] reverse slavery [ __ ]
right I'm a monster [ __ ] luxury life
every night I'm laughing trippin get the
girl my seven [ __ ] you heard lots of
critters believe she will call like she
picking up concert tickets spinning like
a good mistake Kelly rapidly become a
[ __ ] oh good Thank You snapped out